alguna vez has tenido que tomar una
decisión importante en tu vida pero no
te convencía ninguna de las opciones que
tenías para elegir
a mí me ocurrió esto hace varios años
cuando estaba terminando la carrera de
química se aproximaba el final y no
sabía muy bien si estudiar un máster si
dedicarme a la enseñanza a la
investigación a buscar trabajo para una
empresa vamos lo que se llama están más
perdidos que una aguja en un pajar
para colmo todos mis compañeros de clase
tenían claro su futuro querían dedicarse
a la investigación
por lo que la presión que tenía sobre mí
era aún mayor
sin embargo una cosa tenía muy clara
no quería dedicarme a algo que me
gustara
quería dedicarme a algo que me apasiona
así que abandoné al grupo de los
investigadores para buscar una forma que
me hiciera a mí realmente ver la vida de
forma más motivada
varios días después ocurrió algo que me
ayudó a aclarar mi futuro
estaba estudiando el último examen de la
carrera y llegó a casa mi sobrina
pequeña andrea de 8 años y me preguntó
tito por qué no te dejas de tantas
fórmulas y de tantos apuntes y me
explicas la ciencia de forma sencilla
para que yo pueda entenderla así que fui
a la cocina cogió un poco de vinagre
y un poco de bicarbonato
y le mostré que podíamos llenar un globo
con el dióxido de carbono que generaba
aquella reacción
aquello a ella le resultó bastante
curioso
y esa tarde estuvimos más de tres horas
haciendo experimentos con materiales que
encontramos en casa todavía me pregunto
cómo pude aguantarme durante tanto
tiempo
ese día comprobé en primera persona la
capacidad que tiene la ciencia para
captar la atención de cualquier niño
es más con lo inquieta que era andrea en
aquel entonces podríamos decir que
aquello estaba comprobado a prueba de
bombas
un día pensé
y si esos experimentos los llevo a un
contexto diferente en el que los niños
necesitan que les estemos su atención y
se las pongamos en otro punto
y si los experimentos que le hago a
andrea se lo hago también a niños y
niñas que se encuentran hospitalizados
en españa ingresan cada año más de 400
mil menores en nuestros hospitales de
los cuales unos 1.400 lo hacen por
nuevos casos de cáncer infantil esto
significa para ellos dejar atrás a sus
familias a sus amigos su colegio sus
actividades diarias para tener que estar
encerrados en un edificio completamente
nuevo para la mayoría de ellos donde no
conocen a nadie sienten miedo y los días
se les hacen eternos
para solucionarlo he creado una red de
científicos y científicas que visitan
las unidades de oncología infantil
pediatría y salud mental de varios
hospitales de españa para realizar
divertidos talleres científicos para
entenderlos fácilmente es como hacer la
sección de ciencia del programa de
televisión 'el hormiguero' en un
hospital eso sí con mucho menos
presupuesto y un poco más de rigor
científico
aquí podéis ver algunos de los
científicos que forman parte
científicos y científicas que forman
parte de nuestro equipo personas que
ponen cada tarde todos sus conocimientos
de ciencia al servicio de los pacientes
con esto conseguimos que ahora esos
niños que están hospitalizados estén
disfrutando de aquel sencillo
experimento que yo le hice a mi sobrina
pero también que esté observando
extremidades de insecto en el
microscopio o haciendo reacciones
químicas con cambios de colores
con todo ello conseguimos tres objetivos
que me gustaría compartir con vosotros a
continuación
el primero de ellos es aliviar el
ingreso a estos pacientes
los hospitales no son lugares agradables
y estos niños tienen que ingresar de la
noche a la mañana rompiendo con su
rutina están aburridos y sienten miedo
se vuelven tímidos e incluso muchas
veces no quieren ni hablar
sin embargo
ellos poco a poco van cuando vienen a
los talleres científicos van a
participar
van a plantear sus hipótesis van a
trabajar en equipo se van a empoderar y
van a acabar con pacientes con caras
como las que tenemos aquí en la que esa
paciente se está olvidando de todo lo
que está sufriendo y está viviendo en el
hospital para para echarse unas risas
mientras estamos allí
esto que os cuento en primera persona lo
vimos con este paciente un niño que al
entrar en el aula donde hacíamos el
taller científico venía con miedo venía
en silencio y agarrado de la mano de su
madre y de su padre dos horas después de
participar en nuestra actividad salió
hablando
con nuestra bata de científicos puesta
con la maleta en la que nosotros
llevamos todos los materiales y los
reactivos para hacer el taller
científico y pidiéndonos por favor que
continuará moja horas haciendo los
experimentos en su habitación
con todo ello lo que vamos consiguiendo
es que poco a poco
esa sensación que tienen esos pacientes
durante las largas estancias en el
hospital
vaya desapareciendo
que ese miedo esa tensión y ese
sufrimiento
se vaya diluyendo al igual que está
ocurriendo
en este experimento
conseguimos que salgan de sus
habitaciones participen hagan su vida lo
más normal posible como si estuvieran en
en su colegio por ejemplo
esto que estoy haciendo aquí
quiero repetir varias veces no es magia
es ciencia
el segundo objetivo que conseguimos con
esta iniciativa es permitir un respiro a
sus familiares
estos sufren una situación similar a la
de los pacientes de hecho podríamos
decir que los familiares no están
enfermos pero si están hospitalizados
no olvidemos que muchos de ellos tienen
que ir de una ciudad a otra para que su
hijo pueda recibir el tratamiento allí y
no olvidemos tampoco que a veces ese
padre o esa madre tiene que dejar su
trabajo para estar acompañando a sus
pacientes a sus hijos este sillón azul
no solo representa la incomodidad física
que ellos tienen que sufrir mientras
están en el hospital también representa
la incomodidad emocional
sus miedos su duda
qué le pasará a mi hijo
cómo va a acabar todo esto
cuando saldremos de aquí
lo que conseguimos ahora es que esos
familiares vengan con nosotros al taller
que estén disfrutando viendo reír a sus
hijos que puedan salir a tomar un café
que puedan salir a dar un paseo
que salgan de sus habitaciones
que se relacionen con otros familiares
y por qué no e incluso que se echen unas
risas con algún que otro chiste
científico
lo que conseguimos en definitiva
que ese estrés y esa preocupación que
ellos están viviendo mientras están en
el hospital pase de una fase superior a
una fase inferior como acaba de ocurrir
con el agua en este experimento
no es magia es ciencia
el tercer objetivo y último que
conseguimos con esta iniciativa
es fomentar las vocaciones científicas
entre la población infantil y el hecho
de que sea el tercer objetivo no
significa que sea el menos importante de
hecho en españa sólo 13 de cada 1000
jóvenes acaban una carrera científico
tecnológica curioso porque
paradójicamente en esta disciplina en la
ciencia y en la tecnología donde se van
a crear más puestos de trabajo en los
próximos años por tanto existe una
brecha entre las personas que salen de
la universidad y luego las que luego se
incorporan al mercado laboral el
objetivo que tenemos con estos talleres
científicos es que esa brecha se
disminuya pero no sólo eso también que
esos menores conozcan el método
científico y desarrollen un espíritu y
un pensamiento crítico para que el día
de mañana no se crean todo lo que leen y
todo lo que dicen
queremos que esos niños cuando sean
adultos no crean en las pseudociencias
que sepan y estén convencidos porque así
se demuestra que la tierra no es plana
como defienden algunos
que sepan que la homeopatía no es
efectiva
y que sepan también que vacunar a sus
hijos no es peligroso para la salud lo
que es peligroso para la salud es no
vacunar les
con todo ello lo que vamos consiguiendo
es
despertar ese gusanillo científico en
ese niño y en esa niña igual que se han
despertado algunos gases en nuestra
probeta no es magia es ciencia
ese gusanillo fue el mismo que
despertamos entereza
una niña de 6 años que estaba recibiendo
quimioterapia y ahora que cuando
terminamos nuestro taller científico
siempre solemos preguntar o pedirle a
esos pacientes que hagan un dibujo o
escriban una carta para ver cómo se han
sentido
theresa dibujar una científica que
estaba realizando un experimento
aquello a ella
le gustaba y además le preguntamos bueno
theresa a quien de nuestras científicas
ha dibujado y 3a dijo a ninguna esta soy
yo cuando sea mayor
entonces le preguntamos bueno teresa
y tú realmente por qué quieres ser
científica y theresa respondió
yo quiero ser científica
para evitar que el día de mañana otros
niños y niñas pasen por lo que yo estoy
pasando
y si interesa es el día de mañana la
científica que encuentre la solución a
enfermedades que aún no tienen cura como
el cáncer
gracias
[Aplausos]